the house Intel committee vote could be
as early as Monday to publicly release
that bombshell memo on the Russia
investigation or at least that's what we
understand it's a bombshell memo
Republicans who've read it say it
suggests serious surveillance abuses by
top members of the FBI and the Justice
Department President Trump would have to
okay the memos release and the DOJ is
fighting hard to prevent that
let's bring in Wall Street Journal's
Kimberly's wrassle Florida congressman
Matt Gaetz a member of the House
Judiciary Committee and bill Gavin a
former assistant director of the FBI's
New York office great to see all of you
uh let's start with you congressman
gates I talked to one of your colleagues
earlier this evening and he said the
following a Republican nod is a senior
House member he said I'd be careful in
hyping the contents of this memo he said
I think some of my colleagues are
overselling what's in it this is not the
smoking gun that's going to stop the
Muller investigation and I think they're
building up people's expectations to a
ridiculously high extent I heard that
and this is someone I really respect and
it made me nervous
congressman I would say that the memo
has to be evaluated in the context of
all the other stunning information that
we've learned everything from Andrew
McCabe's email saying that there would
be a headquarter special and a
pro-hillary bias to all the other text
messages between Lisa Paige and Peter
struck that show a real hatred for
Donald Trump and not only a bias but an
intent to act on that bias in a way that
would undermine his presidency and so I
think yes the memo in and of itself
doesn't tell the full story but in the
context of everything else we've learned
I think it shows us that the Muller
probe is rotten to the core
built on a rotten foundation Kimberly I
want to go to you into the issue of the
dossier dossier which I think the
Democrats have tried to kind of push off
to the side it looks like this was used
multiple times in order to justify the
ongoing surveillance of the Trump
campaign and then maybe going forward
what does the public really need to
understand about this because I think
some people here dossier
they think oh the Republicans are into
their conspiracy theories and it's just
too much for me to comprehend right now
but what on a Friday night can we tell
the viewing public about why that
particular issue is so important well it
has been reported that it was used and
hopefully this memo will confirm whether
or not that's true but here's why this
matters if that is indeed in the memo
Laura then that in its of itself is a
modern-day political scandal that is
nearly unrivaled because what you are
fundamentally saying is that there was a
campaign document that was paid for and
produced by one presidential campaign
and the FBI FBI used it as a
justification to spy on a rival
political campaign and I don't care what
your political affiliation is you should
be terrified that something like that
could happen and that bar needs to be
set that it this in itself is a
terrifying idea because you already seen
people that keep moving the goal posts
in this about what counts as shocking or
what counts as scandalous this just
needs to be viewed as bad in and of
itself if that's the case well let's
move on to the effect that this might
have had on the morale at the FBI we've
been hearing a lot from Democrats so
usually our big critics of law
enforcement especially on the state
level who say well the this scrutiny of
the FBI and this relentless criticism is
going to hurt FBI retention and it's
going to shake the public's confidence
in this institution mr. Gavin your FBI
veteran your view on that those kinds of
things as stated Lord simply to further
their own cause in their own belief the
bottom line is the fine men and women of
the FBI will go on doing their job day
after day and do it in a superior man
their badges are not tarnished by the
actions of somebody else their badges
are as shiny as ever the only badge is
tarnished out of this whole thing are
the badges of the people that performed
in a horrible manner if in fact that's
provable and I go back to the wick him
said the this whole thing of the the
problem with the predicate
nation for the application for a FISA
warrant if that's a problem when it
appears that it probably is that's
atrocious because it puts in jeopardy
future fights and warrants going before
fights the judges and courts and that I
mix it all up and it makes it all seem
political it this is supposed to be an
agency getting to the truth balls and
strikes objective we start using the FBI
for political hit jobs and then you know
all bets are off and that's that to me
is really disturbing I mean I lived in
the old Soviet Union as a student that's
what they did there and and so they told
like they like to call Trump a little
dictator and oh he's a dictator he is
dick you know he's an autocrat I find
this to be much closer to police state
tactics than anything they've accused
him of and congressman I'm gonna go back
to you on this the fact that we still
have agents working and investigators
lawyers working in this investigation
with such clear at least the appearance
of a conflict in a conflict of interest
appearance of partisanship and animus
toward the president after everything
we've learned - is stunning whether it's
Jean Erie or whether it's you know
Andrew Weissman or or any of these other
people that they're still in the
investigation that's amazing well and
one of the things I can say about this
intelligence memo is that names are
named and so we're going to be able to
see who is engaged in conduct that has
shocked me and so many of my colleagues
in the Congress and I think that the
result of all of this should be
bipartisan legislation to actually
reform these processes so that you don't
have these folks sticking around after
bad acts
you've got more oversight more
transparency and then we can restore
confidence in the FBI and Department of
Justice look we don't enjoy beating up
on these entities that are essential to
preserve our democracy we just want to
see them work for the American people
not for the interests of a political
party that's trying to do a hatchet job
on someone who's been elected president
the United States and Kimberly before we
let you go the move to focus on whether
Trump was itching to fire Muller
said something whether it's he was
frustrated or and Magan said you do that
I'm gonna I'm out you know I'm not I
think the White House is maybe disputing
that it's unclear and presidents back
from Switzerland now but to me that
doesn't surprise me
if the president truly feels like it's
an unjust investigation and then
investigators who are working on it are
themselves biased or Clinton or Obama
loyalists you know I'd be frustrated too
I wouldn't fight I wouldn't move to
firemen but I'd be frustrated well
there's no crime in asking questions to
and in the confidence of your inner
circle raising questions about whether
or not there are conflicts whether or
not there is bias and whether or not
that that is a cause for any sort of
action the important thing is he didn't
take action in the end and so now we
spent two days talking about a thought
that went through president Trump's head
and we keep hearing from critics of the
president that the the right or
conservatives engage in diversionary
tactics I think there ought to be a
little bit of self-reflection there
because the discussion we're having at
the moment is what happened in 2016 in
terms of the FBI the Mueller
investigation continues unimpeded and
now we need a little bit of truth within
that agency in the Department of Justice